i hope you can all hear me
um perhaps you can indicate
uh it would someone
if you could see the other there we go
with someone perhaps in the chat area
indicate that they can hear me
i'm not so familiar with this
oh yeah yes
yes all right we're ready to start so
we'll get back to the presentation
which is
no
listen
okay so i've entitled this seven steps
to improving your english i'm going to
speak slowly and clearly i hope
i hope even people who
are not confident or don't speak english
well
will also attend this webinar
and ask questions
i have deliberately chosen a time
which is
convenient for people in asia
in japan or korea or china
the last time i did a webinar
it was in the morning
my time here uh pacific standard time
which was convenient for people in
europe and north america but it was not
convenient for people in asia so
as i say here i will speak slowly
people can ask me questions in their
language or in english
if you are a learner of english it's
good practice to use english but if you
want to ask a question in japanese
german spanish russian chinese
uh it doesn't matter i will attempt to
answer
now
uh if you have questions i think you can
see the screen here and you can see
where you uh post your questions
and i will once i finished my
presentation
i will attempt to answer these questions
now
i'm going to talk about seven steps
that are important and they're really
important for learning any language
and i know this because i have learned
quite a few languages myself
and the very first thing is
that you must
you must believe that you can learn
you must believe that you can improve
um this is such an important concept i
see so many people
who
fundamentally they don't think they're
going to improve
and
you know if you're
trying to climb a mountain and you don't
think you can reach the top of the
mountain you won't try very hard
and i know everyone can improve
so i think the first thing the most
important step is you have to believe
that if you put in the time if you make
the effort you will improve
okay
try to imagine yourself becoming a
fluent speaker of english imagine that
you are a native speaker of english i
have done this myself when i learned
french i pretended that i was french
when i learned chinese i pretended that
i was chinese when i lived in japan
and i was talking with a group of
japanese people
i pretended that i was one of their
group
so it's almost like play acting but you
have to believe that you can improve and
you have to imagine yourself becoming a
fluent speaker of english or of any
other language that you are learning
the second thing is
give yourself a clear and attainable
goal
all right now if you simply say i want
to improve
that is a nice goal but it's very hard
to measure because very often
when we're learning a language
we have the impression that we're not
improving
somehow we think that we're more or less
staying at the same level even if we are
not so it's hard sometimes to tell if
we're improving or not however
there are other goals that you can
measure in other words you can say i'm
going to listen an hour a day
and you either listen an hour a day or
you don't but that's a real goal
or you're going to read an hour a day
and you're going to do it for the next
six months let's say you know at least
we have these 90-day challenges
and the reason is because it's very
useful to give yourself a clear
short-term goal
a goal
in terms of your level of activity
in in terms of what you are going to do
not in terms of i want to improve i want
to be fluent
all of these things will come
if you put in the effort
but the first thing is to give yourself
a clear
measurable goal that you can achieve so
that's tip number two and these are all
things that i have done in my learning
the third thing is to get outside your
comfort zone
i see so many learners who only ever
listen
to
lessons and
language content that has been prepared
for learners with lots of repetition
lots of easy vocabulary
spoken slowly and then when they go out
and speak to real people they can't
understand so it's very important as
early as possible
move away from
learner material textbook material find
things of interest
which nowadays we can find on the
internet
i happen to be studying polish and i
have found wonderful material on polish
history novels which i am learning and
i'm using of course link to acquire the
words and phrases but the material that
i'm listening to and reading is
interesting
everyone i think should have as a goal
to read a novel in english or the
language you're learning
you have to you can't always just read
short text prepared for you at the
school so get outside your comfort zone
that's the the third
tip now we will be sending you a pdf of
this whole presentation so if you're not
you needn't worry about taking notes you
will get this and you will also receive
a recording of this presentation
now the next thing is
treat learning english as a game in a
way
i always feel
that when i'm speaking a foreign
language i'm playing a game it's it's
imaginary it's make-believe
and to that extent and for that reason
sometimes it's less stressful it's a
game so sometimes i make a mistake but
it's magic it's magic because it's a
game and so it's very important that i
listen to things that i find fun and
interesting and when i'm speaking i
pretend i'm an actor i i have fun with
speaking this other language it's it's a
world of of make-believe i pretend that
i'm
chinese or french or russian
so try to have fun with it
okay that's very important
because language learning takes a long
time so you want to enjoy yourself while
you're learning
now here again
we are always going to forget words we
are always going to forget grammar rules
learn to be happy when you forget words
and happy when you forget grammar rules
and why should you be happy
because
there is a lot of research on how the
brain learns and when we learn and
forget
and relearn learn a second time
we learn it better
if we try to sit there and learn a list
of words and force that list of words
into our brain
the brain starts to push back and it's
very difficult to learn but if you learn
and then forget that you kind of knew
the word but you couldn't remember the
word that's good because the next time
you will maybe forget it again but by
the third time you will learn it very
well
so remember learning and forgetting is
at the heart of learning a language and
it's at the heart of learning english
the same applies to making mistakes be
happy when you make mistakes you have to
make mistakes if you are not making
mistakes then you're
not getting outside of your comfort zone
the mistakes are your friends because
very often you know when you made a
mistake in fact
sometimes you'll
say a word correctly one time
and make a mistake the next time and the
next time you say it correctly
and and this is natural and when you
notice your mistakes even after you've
made the mistake you notice it
this is good it helps you notice the
language so making mistakes is also
helping you to learn so be happy when
you make mistakes
and
now the final tip is and this is
extremely important trust your instincts
and just communicate
don't try when you're speaking you know
try to be sure you got the right
word or that you said it correctly
if you listen a lot and if you read a
lot your brain is slowly becoming
accustomed to english
and so when you speak
you're going to speak based on what the
brain naturally wants to say your
natural instincts and you will gradually
improve
and so if when you speak you try to
remember grammar rules and you're trying
to be so careful in fact you won't speak
as well and you won't speak naturally if
on the other hand you just let go and
trust your instincts you will speak
better and you will also improve
so
those are my seven tips
as i say any of you who have signed up
will be receiving a pdf and a recording
and we also want to i want to thank you
for attending
and uh
as a token of of my appreciation
you can
with this coupon code
one month free you can get a free month
at link
so
uh now let's move
and also of course we would love to hear
uh what you thought about today's
seminar
and of course now we would like to go
to the question and answer period so i'm
going to switch this if i know how to do
it here
and uh now where is
uh hmm
no i have to find no that's not it here
mark
so how do i get to the
question and answer here
well i finished presentation now how do
i get to the questionnaire
i've been we're sorry here i'm not so
proficient at this
area
okay
all right now
we're going to get to questions it
should start in 10 minutes
let's see here
well i see a number of people
from different countries
and remember to send in your questions i
don't see any i heard i cannot hear
anything
okay
first question here from gabrielle silva
should i search every word that i don't
know
every time i come across it
um
you know it depends
what stage you're at
in
in in language learning
um if i'm reading a book
not at the computer i tend not to look
up words
but i don't read a book away from the
computer until my vocabulary has reached
a sufficient level so that i can read a
book comfortably
and so
most of the time
when i'm reading i'm reading a link
and every word i don't know for those of
you who are who are familiar with link
if i see a word that i'm not familiar
with
i will immediately save that word to my
database i will see some dictionary
definitions
that word is now changed from blue to
yellow
that word the next time i come across it
in my reading it'll be highlighted in
yellow
i do a number of things with it so i
tend if i am reading
on link i tend to look up every word
that i'm not sure of
on the other hand if i'm away from the
computer i don't bother looking things
up and the reason is because when i look
things up in an ordinary dictionary it's
very time consuming and we forget we
forget when we look things up in a
dictionary so in link if i look it up i
know that that the next time i come
across that word it'll be highlighted in
yellow to remind me that i have seen the
word before and i review the meeting
again and and so forth but if i just
look something up in a dictionary
once i close the dictionary it's gone so
once i'm reading on my own i tend not to
look the word up
uh here we have let's see
uh okay
when and how can i find native english
speakers to practice in speaking you
would have to google uh language
exchange there are a lot of people who
offer language exchange and people who
might be interested in learning
your
language uh question flash cards are
they good for acquiring vocabulary you
know it's very much a matter of what you
like doing
i don't
spend a lot of time with flashcards i
review my words in context while i'm
leading
reading
uh
but for those who like using flashcards
many people swear by using flashcards
question how many words per week like um
you know since i started in the polish i
think i've acquired another you know in
a month uh ten thousand new words so
that's a lot
however uh i speak uh you know russian
and czech and ukrainian to some extent
so that helps me with the polish
um now let me just go back up here
the coupon code again all right
um
let's just see i will before i close it
out you'll get the coupon code
when you receive the pdf file so
so you will receive the coupon code for
those of you who didn't who weren't able
to write it down
uh no let me just see here how does
webinar work well webinar is simply a
presentation over the internet what do
you think about the idea of speaking
from day one what do you think of
methods
like michelle thomas
i am not a believer in speaking from day
one
uh but some people like doing that the
reason is that i like my learning
activities to be meaningful
uh day one i have very few words i don't
understand i can't communicate i can't
speak
so
um i prefer to spend my time listening
and reading
and i delay speaking until i'm actually
able
to
understand what people are saying and
that depending on the language it might
be three months it might be six months
before i start speaking however there
are people who like to speak earlier and
when i lived in japan of course i was
surrounded by japanese people so
i would probably you know start speaking
much earlier um
how much input do you have to listen to
to get easy to communicate i mean these
are you you know i can't give you a
number you just have to
experience it yourself uh i think
starting from scratch
a good three months
makes you much more
comfortable
uh in in understanding and then pretty
soon you have the confidence that you
want to start speaking
yeah i hear someone says in scientific
writing once i began reading articles by
underlying phrases that i could use
myself my writing improved immensely of
course
the ability to write well and to write
for example academic
texts or business english
requires you to read a lot to read a lot
and when you read
underline key words and phrases this is
sort of equivalent to what we do at link
i i save a lot of phrases at link
because these are phrases that i want to
be able to use question should i choose
an ex an american or a british accent
this is entirely up to you it depends
what you consider more useful to you or
which one you are more interested in
uh now let's go up here
what do you think the main course for
students in school have learned 10 years
or more english but cannot still speak
uh
yeah a lot of people study english at
school
but um
i think sure they should speak more if
they can
but i still think a lot of that time was
spent in class listening to non-native
speakers a lot of explanation of grammar
i think
people should
find subjects of interest novels
audio books
things that are of interest to them
and spend a lot of time with it and of
course if you have the opportunity to
speak take advantage of that opportunity
but
a lot of people have studied for 10 or
12 years still can't read a novel they
still can't understand movies so i
always feel that if you have a strong
base in your listening and reading
capability
that the speaking capability will
develop from that
how many hours a day do you dedicate to
polish study well it depends on what
other things are happening in my life uh
right now i'm on holiday with my two
sons my wife and we're celebrating my
70th birthday so we're busy and i don't
have much time for polish uh we also had
visitors in september from sweden and we
traveled around the province so i had no
time but when i don't have visitors i
would say that i spend an hour and a
half a day
perhaps 45 minutes listening and another
hour and a half
reading
a person says i always try to listen to
cnn but it is hard to understand should
i continue or choose something easier
i would continue but i for example i
don't listen to things that i don't
understand so for example in my polish
i have an audio book and i also have the
text for that audiobook
and so therefore
if i listen and i don't understand then
i can read and i can say the words and i
can listen again
so
you know it's important to to listen to
things where you have a chance of
understanding it or if sometimes if
you're very familiar with the context
then that helps you to understand it
uh but just to understand things to
listen to things that you don't
understand
um
it's not something that i would do just
having noise on in the background i
don't think that helps a lot
uh
some people are saying uh
congratulations on my 70th birthday
thank you very much
uh
okay
now a lot of people say i want to find
someone to talk to this is true
it's important to find people to talk to
but make sure that your skills your
comprehension skills
um are
good enough because you want to be able
to understand what the other person is
saying
and
you know i always feel very
uncomfortable if i don't understand i am
more
concerned about understanding and if i
have trouble expressing myself it
doesn't matter but if i don't understand
and i also
and i always have to ask i beg your
pardon excuse me i feel very
uncomfortable so
make sure you you
work on your your listing and reading
and then google for different language
exchange opportunities and at least we
also have the opportunity to talk to
native speaker
tutors here's a question does age have a
factor on learning do you think now your
ability for learning okay i am 70
yesterday and i think i'm a better
language learner today than i was 50
years ago
uh i've learned more languages in the 10
year in the past 10 years
than at any similar 10-year period in my
life so i don't think age has anything
to do with it i think it's more a matter
of interest
motivation confidence
and making sure you spend enough time
with the language i have a dutch accent
how can i lose it is it even possible to
lose an accent
this is very individual
um
you know i had
a banker
who was swiss
and who spoke with a very happy sweet
chuck sent like this
and yet he spoke english better than
most native speakers his use of words
his ability to express himself all of
this was better
than um
most canadians so i wouldn't worry about
access uh if you want to try to reduce
your accent
very often it's a matter of the rhythm
and the intonation uh you can listen to
content for example if you're using link
you can listen to
uh some of the audio and then and then
say the same sentence yourself trying to
imitate the intonation and not worrying
so much about
individual sounds but rather getting the
intonation right but
personally um
i think that um
you know one shouldn't be too concerned
many people that i deal with speak
flawless english better than many native
speakers and they have a slight accent
um yeah so pronunciation it's it's just
a matter of i think getting the rhythm
of the language a lot of listening if
you have
what helped me in chinese for example
where there are tones
was that i um had some favorite uh
material
uh
like comic dialogue that i used to
listen to where i i liked the uh the
voice i liked the uh the
rhythm and if you can find an audiobook
or a speaker or someone that you like
and you like the voice just listen to it
over and over and over again
yeah if somebody says here when i listen
to a uk accent or a math class with an
indian accent i end up with that accent
yes to some extent we are very as if we
are learning a language and another
language we are easily influenced by the
accent we're listening to
this doesn't happen in our own language
we tend to stay with the accent that we
had as
as as children it's kind of hardwired in
us but when we're when we speak a
foreign language we tend to be easily
influenced so the only solution there is
make sure you listen to a lot of
of content of the kind of accent that
you would like to
imitate uh here again someone says i
feel afraid to speak to native
native speakers
they will question my ability in doing
other things yes
we are afraid
that when we speak a foreign language
then we somehow sound less intelligent
than when we speak our own language
and that is so and it can't be avoided
when you speak your own language you
have a big vocabulary you have complete
control
you're able to express yourself
very well perhaps elegantly and when you
speak a foreign language you can't
there's nothing you can do about it
except that you should continue
listening and reading and speaking at
every opportunity and not worrying about
people don't judge you because you speak
with an accent
you know how many years to reach a
native level very few people are going
to reach a native level i don't think
that should be the goal i think the goal
should be just to improve our ability to
communicate
and that is best done as i say
now here's a question do you think that
choosing a topic is good to develop
vocabulary for that topic
well again i most of my conversations
are natural so i don't necessarily
choose a specific topic i just talk i
choose a subject that i like to listen
to or to read about
but yeah i don't worry too much about
preparing
you know vocabulary ahead of a
conversation because in fact there's a
bit of research that shows that
preparing the vocabulary ahead of a
conversation really doesn't work very
well because you end up not really
remembering
that vocabulary just communicate
so is it bad to listen to the same
record many times
um to some extent when you're starting
out it's not a bad thing to do but i
think later on it's better to listen to
things that are interesting
but uh yeah a lot of people are
concerned about their
uh pronunciation now how can i use my
once month free in my existing account
where do i put it down
uh i i i honestly don't know the answer
to that question but i will find out
now
do you think choosing now let's see what
else we have here
what is your source for listening well
it depends on the language i mean i've
had to find material for languages like
czech and romanian and portuguese and
and korean and you have to search you
have to google one thing you can do is
if you don't know how to say in your
target language say you're interested in
sports or you're interested in economics
then go to google translate
translate that into the target language
and then search on google
and you'll find podcasts or you'll find
other material
okay well i think that's about it
age uh develop a british accent
uh
now let me see if i can find out from my
uh here how many times do you listen to
a lesson okay here's a question how many
times do you listen to a lesson
um
i
again at the beginning i listen often
because i can't understand that i listen
once i don't understand i listen once i
read i understand some i listen again i
still don't understand and so initially
i might listen five ten fifteen times
but very soon i move on and i don't just
listen to one lesson i listen to one and
then two and then three and then back to
one and two three four and back to one
but within a month or so
this is becoming boring
and so i tend to want to challenge
myself to listen to more interesting
material so i will often move on before
i fully understand the last lesson
question here reading 19th century
novels good or bad i liked reading 19th
century novels when i was learning
russian i read a number of 19th century
novels i enjoyed balzac in french
you know it prometheus posey in italian
uh i like but it's it's a matter of what
you're interested in
how steve should we how many times
speaking to tutors online every time 15
minutes not enough
personally i find that when we are very
much beginners 15 minutes is a lot
because it's difficult to maintain the
conversation for 15 minutes but as we
get better we can go for half an hour an
hour once a week twice a week that's
kind of what i would recommend
um
do you use to learn entire useful
phrases start speaking another language
you know i i save phrases important you
know useful phrases uh in the case of
english for example okay here we have a
phrase in the case of english insofar as
english is concerned these are phrases
very useful phrases that help us
introduce our thoughts i would try to
learn phrases like that uh
learning phrases is an important part of
learning a language but you can't sort
of collect a bunch of phrases and start
using them you have to it's more a
matter of noticing them noticing them i
save them when i'm studying and slowly
they sort of become part of the words
that i can use
uh we had a question here people who are
members what can they do with their
coupon
okay so then the free coupon at this
point is only for new members we are
trying to attract new members
to to links so i'm terribly sorry that
at the present time but it's something
we should think about perhaps in the
future we will have something for our
loyal and existing members whom we very
much appreciate
uh
all right uh song lyrics absolutely if
you like listening to songs and if
you're singing along you're practicing
the songs
uh that's a good thing to do
now a person here says google translate
doesn't always translate it correctly
this is true however it depends how you
use google translate
when i wanted to find a polish podcast
on history i went and you know uh
history yapolsky podcast i put that in
there and up came what i was looking for
or ebooks or whatever it might be so
you just have to learn
to use
these uh
you know tools like google translate for
what they are but they aren't perfect
so okay i think we've more or less
covered everything i've answered most of
the questions
that i found uh let us know what you
thought
of the uh of the
webinar and we hope to have more of
these
and anyone who signed up is going to
receive the pdf and the recording
and of course the pdf will have the
coupon there so that you can
get your free month at link
and we wish you uh
success in your language learning
now here we'll give a few more showed up
a few more questions
uh okay is it possible
to improve my speaking skills only by
watching videos
okay
you know ultimately
in the end to speak well you have to
speak a lot
so you have to find people to speak to
but
if you don't have a lot of people around
you you can build up your vocabulary
build up your comprehension skills
through a lot of listening and reading
the biggest thing when you go to speak
to a native speaker is you want to make
sure you understand what the native
speaker
is saying and the native speaker has a
much bigger vocabulary than you do
all right
what do i think of the gold list method
i tried it
but
i wasn't able to continue it it just it
ended up
taking a lot of time
and it's you know
my preferred way of learning words is to
simply
read in link
and i'm constantly reminded of words
that i have
met before and saved and i just find
that quite naturally unconsciously if
you want i make you accumulating lots of
words
writing up lists of words it's just not
something i like to do but
many people like to do it so it's a
matter of what you of what you like to
do
okay
thank you very much and we look forward
i look forward to doing this again and
we will let you know when the next
webinar takes place
thank you
bye for now